[Générique d'intro]
[hors champ] : Donc, votre agression a eu lieu
hier soir, c'est ça ?
Est-ce que vous avez vu l'agresseur ?
Eh bien ça va peut-être nous aider. On va faire un portrait robot,
et si il est dans la base de données, PAF, on l'attrape. D'accord?
J'ouvre le logiciel.
et je vous pose quelques questions.
Et je vous pose quelques questions.
On est parti.
Alors, est-ce que votre agresseur est un homme ?
Oui... Bon c'est des questions de base, euh... Donc, oui.
Oui. *clic*
Est-ce que votre agresseur aurait plus de trente ans ?
[voix chancelante] : - Oui.
- Oui. *clic*
Est-ce que votre agresseur, serait-il, de votre famille?
[voix chancelante] : - Bah, vous rigolez...
- Ben je...
[voix chancelante] : - Ben je veux dire, si c'était un membre de ma famille, dans ce cas-là, je saurais qui c'est.
Oui bah vous me dites non alors.
[voix excédée, faible]  : - Ben non...
- Non... Non, ben voilà.
On s'énerve pas...
Non. *clic* Voilà.
Est-ce que votre agresseur aurait déjà enregistré un disque?
[incrédule] : - ... Enregistrer un...
- Un disque ?
Mais comment vous voulez que je le sache ?
Enfin je veux dire, c'est quoi ces questions?
Comment vous voulez que je sache si mon agresseur... J'en sais rien s'il a enregistré un disque, je...
On se calme, on suit le protocole, on répond aux questions, vous savez pas vous dites non.
Excusez-moi.
Est-ce que votre agresseur serait-il
décédé?
Uh, je vais marquer non.
Non. *clic*
Est-ce que votre agresseur aurait-il
des origines asiatiques?
Oui.
Ah.
Oui ?
Oui, attendez.
Est-ce que votre agresseur, serait-il, un humoriste?
Mais oui.
Attendez, attendez.
Est-ce que votre agresseur aurait-il une chronique télé ?
Mais c'est ça !
Mais oui il a une chronique télé !
J'ai trouvé ! C'est Jean-Luc Lemoine !
C'est lui, j'le reconnais ce p'tit fils de p*** !
Et vous l'avez trouvé !
Eh ouais, on va vite nous.
En quelques clics en plus, seulement !
Ecoutez, je sais pas de quoi on m'accuse...
Mon client ne parlera pas, et je ne sais pas qui est ce délateur qui est Akinator.
Mais au vu de son accoutrement : un p'tit gilet et un turban sur la tête,
je ne pense pas qu'il ait ses papiers de nationalité française. Merci à tous.
[Outro]